on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
[Music]
TV tonight on pbor on sensor Ben Shapiro
is one of the most influential Jewish
commentators in the world as Terror and
tragedy rocked Israel Millions have been
gripped by his powerful and
controversial commentary tonight he
joins me exclusively and
[Music]
uncensored
live from the news building in London
this is Pier Morgan uncensored good
evening London welcome to PE Borg on
sensitive 5 days ago terrorists from
Hamas attacked Israel they murdered and
raped civilians they executed the
elderly of bus stops they took babies
and Holocaust Survivors as hostages and
they massacred young people at a
festival they may and emerged last night
have even beheaded babies in one Village
more than 12200 Israelis are now
believed to have died and this brutal
attack has dragged Israel into war
Israel had every right to respond with
Force as it's done the death toll in
Gaza is now more than a thousand and
many more will die many of those will be
completely innocent people like those
who died in the Hamas attacks like
almost everyone I've been shocked and
sickened by the stories and videos
emerging from the attack I've Al also
been stunned by the moral cowardice of
those who celebrated Terror as
resistance and brutality as politics
I've called out the people who've confed
a terror attack with a geopolitical
debate and I've spoken to fair-minded
people on both sides of that debate I've
done this as a journalist and a human
being but with no personal skin in the
game my guest tonight on the other hand
is one of the most prominent and
influential Jewish commentators on the
planet Ben Shapiro has been visibly
moved and enraged by the tragedies
unfolding in Israel and the world has
paid attention to his analysis tonight
I'm giving the show to him as we tackle
all the big questions that have come out
of this what is a proportionate response
to terrorism should the United States be
more involved how do we move forward if
everyone involved sees the other side as
an oppressor or a Savage and M Del wise
Ben Shapiro joins me now Ben uh great to
have you on the program I wish it was
under different circumstances I want to
ask you first of all where were you when
you first heard about these
attacks so I'd been in Israel for
several weeks and we had just gotten
home to uh to the United States on
Friday morning uh Friday night obviously
is Sabbath for for orthodox Jews and it
it also happened to be one of the
biggest celebratory days of the
year was a two-day what we call YT which
means no electricity really you can't
use your phone you can't use your
computer uh my security team showed up
at synagogue on Saturday morning and
started informing me of what had
happened and then news was was kind of
bleeding through throughout the day
there were various sources you know
Maids who were leaving TV on for example
or my security team informing me
throughout the weekend of what exactly
was happening because of the serious
security concerns that arise for Jews
all over the planet when there's Mass
terror attack in Israel or or anywhere
else and um and so you know we were
finding out in uh a lag time what
exactly was happening obviously we
couldn't watch the videos we couldn't
see exactly what was happening until we
came back online on Sunday night and we
hit with the news that at that point 700
Jews have been murdered today that
number is has been total that well over
1,200 Jews have been murdered uh in in
Israel we started to see all of the
pictures on our TVs I obviously because
I'm in touch with with a lot of people
on the ground First Responders uh people
on the ground in Israel I started
receiving extraordinary levels of of
footage and and video and audio and and
pictures of what exactly had happened in
these places and um yeah I mean these
are these are images i' I've been trying
to show them to the audience for for one
very specific reason uh and that
specific reason is to to understand what
evil is you have to look in the face of
evil and I I think that you know we in
the west have a A peculiar narcissism
that we everyone thinks like we do uh
that that we value children a certain
way and so everyone values children in a
certain way that that if somebody does
something truly terrible or evil it must
be that there was something that quote
unquote drove them to it must be a
policy question um but as it turns out
that that is not the case because
there's literally nothing I think here
that could drive people in in the west a
normal person to go and to murder a baby
in their crib uh in in a civilian area
to to Simply walk in and gun down
grandmothers or to rape a woman and drag
her back to the Gaza Strip what what
could drive you to do that I can't think
of anything that would drive me to do
that but there are a lot of people are
not only driven to do that but but
Believe full well in the virtue of what
they're doing that is a different mode
of thought and that is not something you
can negotiate with you've seemed about
this for completely understandable
reasons to have been more enraged than I
think I've ever seen you almost like a
simmering volcano as you've talked about
this I want to play a clip from your
daily wire YouTube channel you have 6
million subscri subcribers and this is
part of what was I thought a very
powerful address that you made
there I am a Jew those have been the
words of the Jewish people for three
Millennia those were the words of the
men women and children of Masada those
were the words of the followers of Barba
those were the words of Jews and Granada
in 1066 and the reinland in 1096 and
ketki from 1648 to 1657 and kishinev in
1903 and kevron in 1929 those were the
words of Jews in aitz and trbl
those were the last words of Daniel
Pearl and those are my words too they're
the words of my parents the words of my
wife my children over the weekend my
people the Jewish people were attacked
and murdered mutilated our women were
raped our children were
kidnapped this has happened millions of
times before to millions of Jews across
history Jew hatred exists because evil
exists because there are people who have
for literally all of human history hated
the Jews and and start to strike at them
while they are weak who have blamed the
Jews for their own problems who have
crafted complex conspiracy theories
about the supposed power of the Jews who
have sought to destroy to murder to
mutilate to rape the Jews from pharaoh
to hmon from Hitler to
Kamas what reaction have you had to that
B I think the reaction has been pretty
strong and and overwhelmingly positive I
I think there there are a lot of people
not only Jews mostly my audience is
people who are not Jewish obviously who
who understand the history
of the Jewish people who understand what
it means when when the greatest
Slaughter of Jews on a mass scale
happens since the Holocaust and and who
understand that it is inextricably
linked to a history of anti-Semitism
that goes back thousands of years I mean
this extermination level anti-Semitism
what you see from Kamas it's literally
part of their Charter and so the attempt
to treat them as a normal political body
obviously is foolish I think that a lot
of people resonated to that it's this
certainly the strongest I felt about
anything that happened in my lifetime
since 911 um as an American since 911
and as a Jew obviously I I'm I'm
watching as people that I know people
I'm friends with are getting called up
to go to the military and serve in Gaza
try to protect the the Israeli citizenry
who are Jews and Arabs who are
Christians and Jews and Muslims and um
and you know I'm watching as you know
there there are people out there who are
rallying on behalf of of actual
terrorist groups murdering children I
mean it's an amazing it's an amazing I
would say exposure of of ignorance at at
at best ignorance at best and Jew hatred
at worse do you have any personal
connection to anyone whose whose life
was
taken uh I don't I'm I'm I'm lucky I
would say that I I have um certainly I
know a lot of people who do so the way
to to talk about the Jewish community in
general there are not very many Jews on
the planet due to conspiracy theories
people tend to think there are tens of
millions of Jews on the planet the grand
total number of Jews on planet Earth is
about 15 million about 7even million who
live in the state of Israel about 6
million who live in the United States
and what that means is that in general
Society you think think you know seven
degrees of Kevin Bacon with with seven
degrees of of connection you can find
anyone in among among Jews that that's
one that number is one so I I certainly
know an enormous number of people who uh
who have had people who are kidnapped
who've had people who are murdered I
certainly know personally enormous
number of people who are on the ground
right now I know Americans who are who
are in Israel with me who decided to
stay over the last day of the yove over
the over the holiday and ended up
basically getting stuck there because
the the airport was shut down because of
Rocket attacks and uh and when the call
went out to everybody with medical
training to to show up to to help I know
American doctors who showed up at the
Gaza border to Simply set up Triage
stations and help people out so I mean
it is it's a very small community it's a
very close net Community
obviously
[Music]
[Applause]
you've spoken a lot about Hamas before
uh called them evil uh you did a second
video called make God avenge their blood
in which you said that Hamas in some
ways they are worse than Nazis which
some viewed as a very provocative
statement why did you say that about
them the the Nazis I mean here's a
phrase I'll never use again at least the
Nazis so at least the Nazis attempted to
hide their crimes and so so the Nazis
obviously mechanized death they had
einot scrap a group in units that they
drove up to to Jewish villages who would
mow people down um and then they would
bury them they would try to hide the
crimes and it took you know the nberg
team years to to undig all of that
material in this particular case you
have Kamas terrorists who are murdering
Jews in their beds and live streaming it
and and celebrating it and bragging
about it and and talking about how
incredible it is and Blasting that sort
of stuff out I mean the videos that I've
been showing on my show a lot of them
are coming directly from Kamas I mean
it's Kamas that that is taking
contemporaneous video of this sort of
stuff and that that's a whole new level
of evil that to to celebrate this sort
of stuff to treat it as a Triumph I mean
I I think the thing that that that
people really have to realize here is
this is not a military operation this
was not a military operation I mean
people have compared this to ex for
example the 1973 yum kipor war that was
an awful moment in Israel's history when
it was taken by surprise by the combined
Arab armies around it but that was a
military operation with a military
objective which was to seize territory
this is not a military operation with a
military objective this was this is an
operation directed specifically at
civilians and and when we see death in
Gaza which we're going to see and the
images are going to be horrifying and
terrible it is important understand that
the reason that that is happening is not
just because Hamas crossed the border
and murdered a bunch of civilians in
their beds but also because Hamas
literally hides its Weaponry behind
civilians Israel is currently right now
sending out messages to Gaz and
civilians telling them to get out of
particular areas and Hamas is sending
out full scale messages telling people
to ignore those messages and to stay
where they are Hamas is is there's a
reason why their headquarters were for
years located underneath a hospital and
it's the the the what they what they
they understand that the West again has
this peculiar narcissism where we think
we would never put our military our
military hardware below a hospital
that'd be insane um and so if Israel
blows up a hospital must be that Israel
is doing that because they're targeting
civilians Kamas knows that that's that's
why they're doing it that's why they're
doing it they literally hide their
rocket launchers behind apartment
buildings in the hope that Israel will
strike back and have to kill civilians
in the process Israel cares
significantly more about civilian
casualties in Gaza than Hamas ever has
one of the I mean there have been so
many horrendous uh images and videos the
poor girl from the music festival taken
away on the motorbike was just bone
chilling to watch um I I saw something
on CNN yesterday with Jake tappa where
he's interviewing the relative of a
grandmother his grandmother who was
murdered and Hamas posted the video of
her being murdered onto her Facebook
page so her family would watch it I mean
when you hear that it's sort of
unconscionable it's it's kind of Beyond
depravity this is in
Humanity I mean Piers you're in the
business of words and I'm in the
business of words and I've found myself
repeatedly over the last few days unable
to to find words to describe the kind of
thing that we're seeing and again we we
stretch I think in the west and I
stretch as an American we I think we all
stretch to try and find you know what
would drive somebody to do something
like this and the answer sometimes is
that they are just they're I don't know
how to say this otherwise they are not
like you Hamas is not like you they
don't think like you they don't have the
same priorities as you they don't have
the same values as you and that means
that any attempt to buy them off is is
bound to fail and and this is
inextricably intertwined with the
history I mean the fact is Israel turned
over the Gaza Strip in 2005 there were
no Jews living in the Gaza Strip since
2005 the areas that were attacked in
this particular terrorist attack are not
areas that are in the so-called
settlements theim in Judea Samaria
What's called the West Bank that that
that's not the area that was attacked
the area that was attacked has been
Sovereign Israeli territory since
1947-48 and and that territory was
attacked from across a border that is
entirely controlled by Hamas which has
utilized pretty much every dollar that
has that has flooded into that region
over the course of 20 years from America
from Europe taxpayer dollars that have
been used to build up these Terror
capabilities you every time there are
cement shipments into into the the area
ruled by Hamas Hamas has used it to
build ter tunnels pipes that have been
sent into the area ruled by Hamas that
were meant to build sewage systems have
been repurposed and used for for Rocket
tubes I mean this is this is in it's
it's utterly insane and to to try and
come up with some sort of territorial
solution this is really just a
territorial dispute it is not a terror
territorial dispute it is is a genocidal
group that makes clear its own intention
I don't know how many times people have
to tell you who they are before you
believe them the reason that I've been
saying that Hamas is genocidal for
literally my entire career is because
they say in their own founding documents
that they are genocidal it's it's not as
though they're attempting to avoid
culpability or responsibility for this
they are saying it out loud they're
begging you to take them seriously also
they're also terrorists I mean let's
just be crystal clear this is an act of
terrorism that we saw at the weekend the
worst since 9/11 one of the worst Terror
attacks in modern history and yet you
have mainstream media the BBC in Britain
refusing to describe Hamas as terrorists
they call them militants even John
Simpson one of their senior foreign
correspondents and editors said it's not
a journalist role to call groups like
Hamas terrorist he says calling someone
a terrorist means you're taking sides
and ceasing to treat the situation with
due impartiality
the BBC's job is to place the facts
before its audience and let them decide
what they think honestly and without
ranting that's why in Britain throughout
the world nearly half a billion watch
listen to and readers there's always
someone who'd like us to rant sorry it's
not what we do but I don't think it's
about ranting to describe acts of Terror
as being committed by terrorists and the
New York Times apparently today actually
changed uh the wording of a story they
they put online and changed the word
Hamas Terror IST to Hamas gunmen as if
they're almost terrified you know
literally I mean how ironic of using the
word terrorist but what is it about
mainstream media two huge examples of it
New York Times and the BBC that they
won't just call this what it
is I think that that a lot of these
groups are afraid of the political
implications of of just calling a
terrorist a terrorist I mean when when
you acknowledge that the government of
of the Gaza Strip is in fact a terrorist
government that has some pretty large
scale implications for a lot of the
political agendas at play because of
course the the great sort of dream of of
the West since at least the Oslo courts
has been that territorial concessions
and that economic concessions would
would solve this problem and when it
turns out that an entire area is
governed by a a government that is in
fact a terrorist government is an actual
terrorist group uh then that has some
pretty significant implications moving
forward for the prospects in the region
and it also suggests that Israel has a
moral duty which it absolutely does to
protect its own citizenry by
eviscerating that terrorist group from
the plan planet and the word terrorist
has a definition and that definition by
any stretch of the imagination is
fulfilled by by what Hamas is I mean the
BBC's explanation is so bizarre it's
almost like suggesting that if you found
a a man who had murdered his wife in an
apartment and you reported on that you
didn't call it murder you just said that
some someone was killed a person was
killed and and and the person was
convicted of murder and you still said
they're not a murder we we don't make
judgments over here and use language
like the word murderer because that
would carry some moral implication well
yes it turns out that murdering entire
family slaughtering entire families
burning them I mean some of the stuff
that I've been that I've been tweeting
out which is stuff I'm getting again
directly from First Responders on the
ground I mean just a few moments ago I
tweeted I wish I didn't have to tweet
out these photos but I think people need
to understand the consequences of
failing to see evil for what it is it
was a it was a photo of some a group of
people in in a kabo called kabut B which
is again near the border where 100
bodies were found and they were
attempting to Simply escape and Kamas
stopped the car and burn these people
alive I don't know how you don't call
that what other goal could you have but
to obscure the morality of the
situation if if you refuse to call
things what what they are I don't it's
it boggles the mind it really truly does
mean what also boggled the mind for me
was uh black lives matter Chicago which
had a Twitter account with 60,000
followers they actually posted a
caricature image of a paraglider saying
I stand with Palestine the paragliders
were of course were the ones who flew in
and killed all the people at the music
festival what did you feel when you saw
that
I mean unsurprising only in the sense
that black lives matter as as an
organization had all sorts of solidarity
statements about Palestine going all the
way back to the the original movement in
2014 2015 um but the but seeing them
actively take up the the imagery of an
actual terrorist attack that's what that
is Palestinians are not famous for their
for their hangliding and the only reason
why that is the image is because literal
terrorists use paragliders in order to
murder civilians at an electronic dance
music festival by the way attended
mostly by people of the political left I
mean those are not right-wing Israelis
who are dancing at an EDM Festival on on
a Saturday that's not the way that that
works um it's it's only astonishing in
either the moral blindness or the
anti-Semitism and at a certain point the
moral blindness becomes the
anti-Semitism because when you are
celebrating Act of Jew murder and you
are saying that that's solidarity that's
a pretty incredible thing I'd also like
to point out here that the argument in
favor of Palestinian self- determination
did not need to be threatened by any of
these people all they could have said is
Hamas does not represent Palestinians
this does not have any for Palestinian
self-determination Hamas is a terrorist
group and they to be eviscerated and
they ought to be replaced by a better
government that could make peace none of
this is particularly hard the fact that
they're lumping together Hamas with the
Palestinian cause says an awful lot and
it doesn't say anything good in one of
the videos you say the only solution is
for Israel to Annex the Gaza Strip and
kill enough sons of [__] to make sure
this isn't a problem again you say
anyone who calls for ceasefire is a
terrorist sympathizer under these
circumstances now that got a lot of push
back uh I guess this comes to the point
of appropriate response how far do you
go how do you isolate genuine Hamas from
perhaps completely innocent Palestinians
in Gaza of which there will be many um
one person called you a genocidal
warmonger for that rhetoric and there's
a a person called Muhammad hijab in a
video called in responding to benir on
Israel he says
this first and foremost I'll say yes we
condemn any woman child or whatever it
may be that's being killed who's Jewish
and who's not a non-combatant but why is
it the case Ben huh why is it the case
that you none of your colleagues or you
have been able to offer one single
condolence one single condemnation one
single word of sympathy for any of the
gazin that have been killed don't try
and smear us don't try and slander us
don't try and attack don't try and
produce red earrings and I think you're
an ass a jackass and we're not talking
about Hamas we're talking about children
here we're talk about women here we're
talking about elderly
people you make me sick you make me
sick what's your response to that B that
will be I'm sure a reaction You' have
heard from a lot of people what do you
feel about that I mean my obvious
response is of course I feel horrible
for the people who are being held by
Hamas in a state of tyranny for the past
15 years Hamas was the elected
government in Gaza in 2006 there hasn't
been an election since then all the
people who are who are today ranting as
as you heard Muhammad hijab doing right
there I don't hear them talking about
liberating Gaza from Hamas which is the
greatest threat to the to the way of
life of gazans on planet Earth again I
have nothing but sympathy for Hamas for
for the people that Hamas is is govern
or the people that Hamas is exploiting
really I have nothing but sympathy for
civilians there Israel has to defend
itself I don't understand exactly what
the expectation would be here is is the
expectation that because Hamas uses
human Shields that Israel therefore has
to go home and wait to be to to have its
people murdered again Israel tried it
the way that that Muhammad hijab and
others would like Israel literally
pulled in 2005 they literally pulled
thousands of Jews out of the Gaza Strip
it was called the disengagement and it
was massively unpopular in wide swats of
Israel they pulled out they built a wall
and they basically said go ahead and
govern yourselves and this is the result
of that you think Israel you think I you
think anyone in Israel no one in Israel
wants to reoccupy the Gaza Strip no one
that's why Israel has been studiously
avoiding reoccupying the Gaza Strip
since 2006 despite the fact that theyve
been living underground in large parts
of Israel for weeks at a time because of
Rocket attacks that been fired on a
regular basis from the Gaza Strip into
major cities let me ask you this in Gaza
you have two million people many of whom
are young people pretty hopeless
conditions to live in I think people
would agree with that uh not much chance
of getting out of there uh they live in
very densely populated areas we know
from in the last 24 hours that Israel
controls water controls Energy power
going in there uh many would see that
that is a control that Israel shouldn't
have if you want to afford equal rights
to people living in in Gaza and then it
comes down to proportionate response and
how you try like I say how do you how do
you attack Hamas given they're all over
Gaza living amongst the general
population how do you attack and isolate
genuine members of Hamas genuine uh
terrorists from the civilian population
and given that is almost impossible
clearly what is a proportionate response
to what's happened here well frankly I
don't believe in proportionate response
to terrorism I believe that the way that
you stop terrorism is with wildly
disproportionate response that doesn't
mean in terms of targeting civilians
means in terms of killing as many
terrorists as humanly possible and
allowing them to dictate the terms of
Engagement by hiding behind civilians in
areas that that they are supposedly
responsible for means that the only
option for Israel is to surrender to
hamas's hatred of its own citizens its
willingness to use its own children as
human Shields no no country worth its
salt could ever do that no no government
trying to protect its own citizens could
ever do that what exactly is the
alternative option other than for Israel
to try to kill as many of these
terrorists into post Hamas and hopefully
help put in place some sort of
International overseen Community that
would actually govern the Gaza Strip in
a in a rational reasonable way that
actually maximizes the possibilities of
its citizens Israel over the course of
the last year allowed some 15,000 work
permits to Gins many of those work
permits we're now finding out were used
by terrorists in order to cross the
border the fact that Israel controls the
water and the power the reason that
Israel controls the water and the power
is specifically because if they did not
control the water and the power Hamas
would be right now hold up with the
water and the power indefinitely I mean
the fact is that the reason that Israel
controls for example the seab border is
because if they did not there were
attempts to ship weapons in from Turkey
multiple times the the The Impossible
situation in which Israel finds itself
with regard to the Gaza Strip is
mirrored only by The Impossible
situation which in which Gaz and
civilians find themselves and all of
that every single iota of that is the
result of Kamas which means unless there
is a change in status in which Hamas is
removed from power in which someone else
is put in charge this is going to
continue
again 10,000 10,000
their citizens I agree with you but I
would also say that I think that it
would also benefit any chance of a peace
settlement that if Netanyahu wasn't in
charge anymore um I mean apart from
anything else this is an unbelievable
breach and failure of of security and
Military I think part of that can be
apportioned to the extraordinary social
unrest that's been enveloping Israel
since his cabinet full of a lot of
right-wing he bangers frankly some of
whom actually called themselves fascists
uh have tried to take on the Judiciary
and the Supreme Court I don't feel
comfortable about that what do you feel
about that and do you feel that
Netanyahu is the right person should
does it need a completely clean
leadership now both in Palestine and
Israel to try and get to somewhere
approaching peace the democratically
elected government of Israel has not had
a change in policy despite the fact that
until very recently Netanyahu was not
the prime minister of Israel it was a
joint government run by naali Ben as
well as by Yer Leed who's a member of
the hard left who dramatically opposes
Benjamin Netanyahu today they formed a
Unity government between Benny Gans
who's a member of the center left and
Benjamin Netanyahu who's a member of the
centrer right leud party in Israel this
is not when it comes to foreign policy
the reality is that since the rejection
of any peace deal by Mahmud abas in 2009
when Aur was the Prime Minister of
Israel there's been very little
disagreement between any of the parties
with regard to foreign policy because
they do not have a peace partner the Osa
process was killed by the Palestinians
and it was killed by the Palestinians
when when they rejected multiple peace
offerings by AUD Barack by Ariel shiron
by ahud om over and over and over again
by Yak Rabin by Shimon Perez Benjamin
Netanyahu himself in the wide river
Accords of 1998 handed over significant
portions of the West Bank to the
Palestinians so you can say that
Netanyahu is a problem that's fine but
the reality I was already asking you
whether I was asking you whether you
feel he is a problem that actually all
the division that's been caused by his
attempt to usurp the power of the
Supreme Court as many people see it all
that division in Israel has actually
diminished his authority uh and that
it's come at a time when you really need
somebody with real Authority well I mean
I I don't think that right now that's
really the question considering again
it's a Unity government and I'm talking
to everybody in Israel and all of those
divisions heal up in a moment when your
children are being slaughtered at the
border as it turns out so you know all
of the judicial reform conversation is a
separate conversation we can critique
how fast they went in terms of this
coalition they went too fast they scaled
it back there were serious divisions in
Israeli Society about what kind of power
the Judiciary ought to have there are
many people on both sides actually who
believe that Judiciary had too much
power there are a lot of people on both
sides who believe the government went
too fast on that internal political
divisions have become completely
irrelevant here if if nanyo were
replaced tomorrow by Benny Gans which is
what a lot of Israelis would hope for if
if that were to happen literally
tomorrow nothing would change nothing
would change and the reason nothing
would change is because again this is an
issue this particular issue is about
Hamas this has nothing to do with the
consti of the Israeli government you
could find the most leftwing person in
in Israeli politics right now which
would be arel Leed you could put him
back in the Prime Minister seat and he
would be forced with exactly the same
decisions that Netanyahu is faced with
right
now good evening I'm P Morgan uncensored
in New York City King pi and King Q I
think there's only room for one king man
you know what I'm saying he's mock your
weight Trump yeah look at him fail St
working just cuz they're skin folk don't
mean they're kin folk do you believe you
can win this war you making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betray keep it
awardwinning Lucy leby will die behind
bars and a senior Doctor Who first
raised concerns about Ley wants NHS
manages to be regulated we needed
answers a lot sooner this is what 7
years down the line I mean it's
completely ludicrous he was clearly
something of the face of the W so was
even more unthinkable if this nurse had
misgendered somebody on a board she'd
have been out the door when they first
got together there were press stories
weighty Katy that would make her a
better princess of wealth cuz you're not
just marrying the man you're marrying
the job that resonates with people gay
Maxwell agreed to be interviewed for the
very first time I he wish I'd never met
him the conservative party can certainly
win the next election can we Lab at 29
imag the can we did he say yes I have
taken drugs and they bent the rules or
lied on the visa application for and
therefore got it the needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God Rest
Souls Let It
[Music]
Roll if we stop producing oil the knock
on effect is far larger than just CO2 I
nearly have empathy when I'm speaking to
them I know now you're probably going to
boot me off show
this some of them they're easily
lit you can kiss my American ass yes
thank you very much very nice of you
Twitter you sons of can you please
reinstate my account thank you there's a
threat that you'd be worried about so
are you saying that you're being
overwhelmed that you're inundated we are
really working hard for you we're just
asking patients to be patient with
us we're now in Barbie world you weren't
asked to give evidence to the Grand
jeury I'm the only one that has been
telling the truth you don't drink never
taken drugs you're stinking Rich should
we be concerned
if it's on your mind it's on talk TV is
about you and your opinions if you're
thinking about it we're talking about
it it's all about me that a
[Music]
joke this is talk
TV take me forward 20 years
in a dream
scenario how does the region look in a
dream scenario Economic Development
which I think is what the Abraham
Accords were about and what the
burgeoning Saudi peace deal was about
and by the way the burgeoning Saudi
peace deal is the reason that Hamas did
this at the beest of Iran they were
afraid of a regional realignment that
would create a Sunni Jewish Alliance
right oriented largely against the the
the Shia power of Iran which is spread
through Lebanon Syria and now down into
into kamasan uh the the you know the
economic development is the only way to
move forward for the region that was the
premise of the abrahamic cors again it
was the premise of the the nent Saudi
peace deal Israel would love to do that
with the Palestinian Authority they
would love to do that with with anyone
governing the Palestinians to provide
better economic conditions I one of the
great ironies of all this is that 20% of
Israel's population is Arab the the
Arabs in Israel earn a far better income
they they have far better GDP per capita
than Arabs who are living under the
Palestinian Authority or under the Gaza
or under the or under Hamas and when you
take polls of Israeli Arabs many of whom
are not particularly fond of the state
of Israel almost zero of them wish to
actually relocate to any of these areas
because economic development is economic
development the the way out of this is
that but in order for that to happen the
people on the other side of the table
have to actually agree that economic
development is a worthwhile thing is an
end goal and this goes back to the
original point that I was making is that
we in the west we believe that Economic
Development worthwhile that what we are
all seeking is the same sort of peaceful
decent life where we leave each other
alone and get to live our lives I think
that we all we all agree on that but
there's a group of people who absolutely
do not agree with that and they don't
care about the level of Economic
Development they would rather live I
mean Hamas would rather that its own
citizens live in poverty and penury and
Orient themselves against the
extermination of the Jews than that
Economic Development even be allowed to
take place I mean every isra government
I I promise you everyone in the Israel
government right to left would love
nothing better than economic development
of the people surrounding them so they
don't have to send their sons and
daughters to go fight and die in Gaza do
you believe in the concept of a
two-state
solution I mean if there were a party on
the other side to negotiate with and if
there if the if the possibility of a
two-state solution was real sure I mean
but the question is how realistic is
that negotiations cannot be the the the
Cure All you can't you have to have a
partner on the other side of the table
the entire premise of the oso Accords is
that you could take an actual terrorist
by the name of yasar Arafat you could
you could negotiate with him you could
make a deal with him and this would
magically cure the situation well a deal
is not capable of being cut with with
literally anyone that's not the way any
of this works so so in order for there
to be any sort of long-term peace
including a Palestinian State there
would have to be a complete difference
in in leadership in in these areas and
that would actually require Palestinian
moderates to take the four the
Palestinian Authority is not a is not a
moderate group Islamic Jihad is a
terrorist group Hamas is a terrorist
group and until that changes nothing's
going to change and by the way there is
the possibility of that change if you
had told me 10 years ago that there
would be Saudi Israeli normalization on
the table I would have laughed in your
face if you had told me that Israel
would have been able to cut peace deals
with the UAE and with Morocco I would
have I would have scoffed and I think
everyone would have scoffed so there is
that possibility but again you cannot
make peace with a side that wants to
murder you that is not a possibility
well on that point all I would say to
that is I'm an Irish Catholic and we had
the troubles in Northern Ireland and in
the end of peace deal was achieved but
it was achieved by people sitting down
opposite people they knew had been
killing civilians and killing people on
their side you even had the queen
meeting Martin mcginness and Jerry ads
who were the uh you know in mcguinness's
case the former Chief of Staff of the
IRA ordered some of the most appalling
atrocities I was actually at number 10
Downing Street when Tony Blair met
mcginness and Adams on the steps for the
first time in in 70 years uh as the
members of shim Fain and shook their
hands I was next in to see him in his
office and it was an extraordinary
moment to watch and it was a moment many
people thought would never happen um do
you see any parallel there in terms of
what could be achieved with Israel and
Palestine only if the leadership changes
only if the leadership changes on the
Palestinian side that is the only way
that happens and again the the the
difference here is that the IRA had
territorial Ambitions Hamas does not
have territorial Ambitions they have
genocidal Ambitions the Palestinian
Authority has been offered multiple
deals over multiple decades and they'
have rejected without counter offers
virtually every deal they' have ever
been offered Islamic Jihad is a
terrorist group again if if the IRA was
dedicated to the complete Slaughter and
eradication of every non-irish britisher
in the UK that would be the equivalent
of Hamas and that would not be a
negotiating position because again could
there be successful negotiations with it
depends on it depends on the partner
right that the example that you're using
is is the best example of sides that are
incredibly far apart coming together but
here we are talking about one side that
simple premise if Israel put down all of
its guns tomorrow every Jew in the
region would be slaughtered if Hamas put
down all of its guns tomorrow Israel
would leave the Gaza Strip alone it is
that simple let me ask you you go to
into a a Twitter spat with Andrew Tate
yesterday he's a converted Muslim he'
been doing a lot of uh supportive tweets
uh for the Palestinians and he tweeted
at one stage Mr tough guy let me assure
you as someone who's done his own
fighting as opposed to excitedly
encouraging others to do it for him
while sitting at home on a comfy chair
peace is always worth a
conversation what what was that spatter
about why did you engage with him what
do you feel about that well what I feel
about that is that he was tweeting that
immediately like as terrorists were
still running around in southern Israel
that was on October 10th and he was
still Tweeting while the bodies were
fresh and warm in the streets We're not
gonna be lectured on morality and
toughness by by Andrew Tate whose great
idea of toughness and morality is
pimping women and then bragging about it
on air and and trying to quasy walk it
back while simultaneously maintaining
many of the same positions and flexing
his
biceps he's got a huge following as you
know especially online is it is it
dangerous is it Reckless that he's able
to tweet from house arrest still of
course in Romania that he can tweet on
something like this and have the kind of
influence that he has listen everyone
should be able to tweet whatever it is
that they want I'm all for an open
discourse even with people who I think
are dead wrong on a lot of these issues
but Andrew Tate is dead wrong on a lot
of these issues and and the the
particularly ridiculous posturing about
being a yes you're very yes you're very
tough when when you want people to make
peace with with terrorists who just
murder their children very very
tough you mentioned Iran earlier uh
President Biden yesterday came out
10-minute speech you know sounded very
tough and very supportive of Israel but
never once mentioned Iran was that a a
failure by him or are they waiting to
establish concrete evidence of Iran's
involvement so I think there's a good
reason he could have done that and a bad
reason that he could have done that and
the bad reason is pretty obvious which
is that the United States has unfrozen
$6 billion in assets to to flood into
Iran in return for hostages that money
is fible and there's every possibility
that money flowing into Iran since since
the weakening of sanctions has
contributed to Iran's spread of Terror
that is not only a possibility that's a
probability and everyone knows it so if
you avoid mentioning Iran then
presumably it avoids blowback that is
the bad reason the good reason might be
that the United States wants to take
down the temperature in the region so
right now geopolitically this is a
contained conflict this is Israel versus
Hamas in the Gaza Strip and everyone of
good heart on every side should hope
that it remains that way if Hezbollah
which is on Israel's northern border and
an Iranian client Hezbollah is a massive
and significantly more powerful than
Kamas terrorist group that exists and
and has say in the government of Lebanon
again Israel is surrounded on a lot of
sides by terrorist groups that
masquerade his governments Hezbollah has
about 150,000 much more sophisticated
Rockets than than Hamas pointed at
Northern Israel everyone understands
that if Hezbollah which would only do
this at the beest of Iran if if
Hezbollah were to get in Israel would
then be stretched militarily to the
point where they would not have any
choice but to go full force and what
that means is that all of the talk right
now about the the supposed
disproportionate force that Israel is
using in the Gaza Strip talk with which
I wildly disagree uh that that will all
go out the window because once you are
stretched to the point of
extermination all bets are off and and
the Israeli Air Force will have to be
Unleashed on the on the southern border
of Lebanon at that point you'd have to
imagine that that Bashar Assad in Syria
starts to get active Iran starts to get
active so one of the things that that
the possible good reason why he didn't
mention Iran is because he's attempting
to keep Iran out of the war that
basically the idea would be he did say
in the speech that any other group that
wants to get in don't America to its
great credit to our great credit we've
stationed a battle carrier an aircraft
carrier outside of uh outside of Lebanon
in the Mediterranean and basically said
tobah that they should not get in uh
that is in fact the the best available
move so again there's a very plausible
bad reason why he didn't mention Iran
which is to avoid the blowback from his
own idiotic Iran policy and there's a
possible good reason which is that he's
attempting to avoid the broadening of
the conflict Donald Trump says as he's
want to do with these crises that would
never have happened if he was President
do you think that may have some truth
I think there's some truth to that for
sure I think that that that Iran has
seen weakness Iran saw an opportunity to
to prevent the Saudis from coming into
to the Abraham Accords and uh they
thought that they could push where they
saw mush I mean the withdrawal from
Afghanistan made America look weak The
Continuous dealings between the United
States and Iran despite Iran's openly
genocidal intentions with regard to
Israel has made America look weak the
fact that Robert Mali who is one of the
chief negotiators for the United States
was apparently co-opted by Iranian
intelligence groups makes the Americans
look look particularly weak and so
appearances of weakness in the Middle
East matter an awful lot it is it is not
politics in western states you where
where we try to negotiate we try to have
discussions that is not how politics
works in the Middle East it is a place
where strength is is really the only
point of the
realm
[Applause]
[Music]
for
the Army veteran had raised more than 32
million when I first walk in the first
thing I see is a luxurious barpool
that's got nothing to do with Captain
Tom we should have done it in a
different way have you had death threats
as a fan there's a forum they were all
discussing how they were going to come
and kill us all did you feel any Quan
being paid from public donations I
should have said no neither of you have
ever made any money directly from the
foundation for personal game not a penny
you've appeared at award C I was paid
£18,000 for that and how much did the
charity get 2,000 what would he be
thinking now looking down on what's been
happening to you articulate how it's
been for you utterly devastating she has
been extremely ill and we all have
there's been genuine times where I don't
think she's known if she could go on
have you felt like ending it
[Music]
all there is a theory that Hamas have
done this spectacularly awful Act of
terrorism deliberately on a scale that
would go Israel into
overreacting and Spark a much a much
wider
War I mean I think that there's probably
truth to that I think that that Hamas I
think that's what ran wants I'm not sure
that Hamas wanted that I think Hamas uh
doesn't want to be wiped off the Earth
which they probably will be and ought to
be um but I think that that Iran's Hope
was that Israel would have to go in
incredibly strong into the Gaza Strip
and this would provide internal pressure
in Saudi Arabia to prevent them from
forming an alliance brokered by the
Americans with the Israelis I think that
was probably the geopolitical reason for
that with that said that does not mean
that Israel has any other choice again
if if if suddenly 1500 terrorists
flooded into Great Britain and proceeded
to murder 15 to 20,000 people because
again Israel is a tiny tiny country it
has 9 million people if if those numbers
were made proportionate if if tens of
thousands of people were slaughtered in
Britain by a group group of terrorists I
I doubt that there' be a lot of British
citizens who are sitting around worrying
about proportionality or worrying about
the geopolitical consequences of
protecting their own citizenry there is
an interesting uh contradiction I would
argue that a lot of uh conservatives in
America a lot of
Republicans have including a number of
presidential candidates from Ronda
santis to Trump uh and others um they
have signaled that they would want to
severely curtail if not stop all
together support for Ukraine and yet
Ukraine was invaded
um by Russia um a lot of people
slaughtered continue to be slaughtered
um is there not a contradiction there
that these Republicans would be me full
Square behind Israel when it happens to
them but not full Square behind
Ukraine I mean yes there's a
contradiction it depends on on sort of
what is being said about Ukraine and it
runs the gamut and some of the
candidates that you've talked about have
talked about ending Aid completely to
Ukraine some have talked about
continuing Aid to Ukraine and and
pursuing some sort of of deal with the
Russians that allows them to keep part
of the dabass and Crimea which I think
is a completely different story and and
is an actual offramp um but yes anybody
who is who is you know sympathetic to
Russia in the Russia Ukraine conflict
and then it's sympathetic to Israel in
this current conflict that that that is
a a bizarre position to take again I
think they're serious America's a
sovereign country it has its own
concerns that are not Israel's concerns
and it has its own concerns that are not
Ukraine's concerns and those those zones
always line up um but when it comes to
you know Poss contradiction between a
completely isolationist position on
Ukraine and an interventionist position
or supportive position on Israel of
course those things could could clearly
be in conflict and my own position by
the way on for what it's worth since I
as you know beers I do this for a living
uh my own position on Ukraine has been
that the United States should continue
to supply Ukraine with the support
necessary in order to preserve its
government and preserve its territory
and meanwhile there need to be serious
talks about what exactly an offramp
looks like in Ukraine because virtually
no one has spelled out exactly what that
looks like and virtually no one believes
at this point Ukraine is going to be
able to completely take back both the
donbas and and the Crimea region that
that is
not been to Ukraine and interviewed
president zalinski and met a lot of
people there and that was quite a while
ago uh there was an unbelievably Steely
resolve and I would I would say the same
resolve that Israel has about seeding
any land now to the Palestinians it's
like they just don't want to give an
inch of land away to the Russians um
that was to a man and woman that I met
out there I have an enormous amount of
sympathy for that position uh again that
that that position does not necessarily
dictate American policy anymore than
than Israel's position with regard to
say the the so-called occupied
territories disputed territories uh
should necessarily dictate America's
position on that there there they're
realistic consequences and concerns to
be had on foreign policy um but if the
point that you're making is that lack of
moral support in invasion of a sovereign
country by by Russia is in contradiction
with moral support for Israel in this I
I I would say yeah I mean there's
certainly inconsistency there I mean the
other inconsistency in contradiction it
seems to me is the reaction of the world
when George Floyd was murdered which was
a Despicable killing and the police
officer concerned uh is now serving a
life sentence quite rightly but that
sparked enormous Global protests uh Over
America over the UK everywhere uh with
people Marching In protest at what they
perceive to be a racist mder Mur of one
person and yet the reaction within hours
of what happened here where as we knew
at the time nearly a thousand people in
Israel have been murdered uh some in the
most utterly horrific
circumstances um the reaction was that
yes there were big protests again but
they weren't really protests they were
marches of
celebration in America in the UK they
marched down my local High Street uh
celebrating what what had happen Pro
Palestinian marches I found that
extraordinary Jew hatred is a very real
thing it's a very real thing and and
we've obscured it with a lot of talk
about Zionism and anti-zionism and we've
obscured it with a lot of talk about
geopolitics and context but in the end
Jew hatred is quite real and when you
see crowds in Sydney chaning gas the
Jews not free the occupied territories
not make a peace deal gas the Jews I'm
not sure what we're supposed to read
into that other than people mean what
they say when they say gas the Jews
yeah I mean that's exactly what they
mean I mean this is this is Nazi
language I mean but as you say the
difference between this and the Nazis
the Nazis tried to keep the secret um
whereas this is all in plain sight I
mean the idea of people doing this in
cities like Sydney and London and New
York it's it's uh it's actually
terrifying and I say that again I'm an
Irish Catholic I'm not Jewish uh I feel
terrified for Jewish people like you say
there's only 15 million Jewish people in
the world uh it must be when this kind
of thing happens in such an
indiscriminate manner it must be
genuinely terrifying for people for sure
and and obviously when you see marches
of support it it the question is always
asked how could the Holocaust have
happened and the answer is this way when
people are are actively in favor of Jews
being murdered simply for for being Jews
and again it's easy people people have
an amazing ability to to justify
whatever it is that they're thinking or
feeling at a given time but if you can
find a way to justify yourself out of
the the murder of of babies in their
cribs I I have a I have a hard time
figuring that it's anything other than
Jew hatred and so if you know a as a Jew
as a person who you know is very
strongly Jewish I'm very active in my
Jewish Community a person with four kids
and and a wife and parents and sisters
and and all of this you know obviously
Jews feel like they are at risk
everywhere because of of of this sort of
activity and and I will say there's an
amazing double standard when it comes to
anti-Semitism and in in the media the
way that it seems to work in the media
these days is if a if if somebody
politically says something about George
Soros then they will be labeled a Nazi
and if somebody actually says I am a
Nazi then they will say well there's
probably some sort of justification over
territorial disputes yeah I want to end
Ben uh on a one positive note and it's a
montage we have of support for uh the
Jewish people and for Israel let's take
a
look
so Ben that last image was of the
Brandenburg gate which of course we saw
back in the 30s with Nazi swas all over
it and today the Israel flag is
emblazened across it proudly and
supportively I mean amid all the Jew
hating and you're right that's what it
is there also been an amazing outpouring
of
support and that is incredible and we
who are Jews obviously appreciate that
and um I would just like to say at the
very end here that that must be
translated into allowing Israel to do
what must be done to protect her own
citizenry because Goodwill only goes so
far as the actual protection of of human
lives and uh if the Jews were to rely on
The Good Will of the world over the
course of history it would have gone
very poorly for them that's why the
state of Israel exists it exists it
never again is never again and in order
for that to be a reality the the IDF the
state of Israel has to be able to defend
itself has to be able to defend its
citizenry and protect them from the kind
of Slaughter and and savagery that we
saw over the weekend Ben shapira thank
you very much indeed for your time today
I appreciate it thank you well that's it
for me tonight whatever you're up to
keep it un sensor good
night
good evening I'm Pi Morgan uncensored in
New York City King pi and King Q I think
it's only room for one king man you know
what I'm saying he's mocked your weight
Trump yeah look at him fail stop working
just cuz they're skin folk don't mean
they're kin folk do you believe you can
win this war you making me cry again
they're trying to force you out yes I
feel betrayed keep it award
winning Lucy Ley will die behind bars
and a senior Doctor Who first raised
concerns about that he wants NHS manages
to be regulated we needed answers a lot
sooner this is what 7 years down the
line I mean it's completely ludicrous he
was clearly something of the face of the
ward so was even more Unthinkable if
this nurse had misgendered somebody on a
ward she'd have been out the door when
they first got together there were press
stories weighty Katy that would make her
a better princess of wealth cuz you're
not just marrying the man you're
marrying the job that resonates with
people gay Maxwell agreed to be
interviewed for the very first time I
see wish I'd never met him the
conservative party can certainly win the
next election can we yes La
29 the rules can we did he say yes I
have taken drugs and they bent the rules
or lied on the visa application for and
therefore got it there needs to be an
intervention around abortion laws
Parliament is Sovereign Parliament can
determine these things the rest of the
world has watched on in sort of mounting
horror as this story has unraveled for
you it was incredibly personal the death
toll from the Titanic tragedy has risen
to 1522 and may God Rest their
[Music]
souls let it
roll wo yes